when Mark bought Instagram for a billion
dollars a couple months earlier I did
some fox program and I said that I was
like it was December they're like hey
make some predictions for 2013 and this
one I am predicting that facebook
acquires Instagram 15 million users for
Instagram probably gonna push 30 next
year and I just have this funny feeling
that the sucks is gonna look at that
Talent look at that apps bring it
in-house I was like Facebook's gonna buy
Instagram right cool whatever
four months later it happens and CNN
asks me to come on because the video
went a little viral in the tech
community so I was on Piers Morgan and
Piers Morgan's show he's his opening
line is this company's five hundred
fifty days old how the hell is it worth
a billion dollars and my opening line is
they stole it I get out of the studio
I'm hardcore Twitter so I go on it and
literally there are thousands of tweets
of people calling me a [ __ ] idiot so
literally that night from like 10
o'clock at night to 4 in the morning I
favorited every single one of those
tweets by hand all of them yeah I think
this is a good story because this is
what an entrepreneur I think does I
favored it them all and then I guess
last year this time right Facebook
bought whatsapp for 18 billion and every
article like the next day after the news
came out is like oh wait a minute they
[ __ ] stole Instagram and no joke for
a week my wife and I went to Turks and
Caicos for a weekend right luckily she
just likes to read and I can't bother
her and I laid on a beach for 19 hours a
day two days in a row and replied to
every single person that called me an
idiot and said what now [ __ ]